[Música]
olá sou muito grata de estar aqui com
vocês hoje compartilham um pouquinho da
minha história e eu quero começar
compartilhando duas observações
a primeira é que mais da metade da
população mundial hoje já vive nas
cidades pode parecer pouco porque já
somos muitos milhões de pessoas
porém se a gente se aproxima esse número
da nossa realidade aqui no brasil mais
de 85% da população já vive nas cidades
isso quer dizer o quê que por escolha ou
por falta de escolha as cidades estão se
tornando o principal destino da nossa
espécie
a segunda observação é que quando
estamos conectados à internet
nós podemos interagir com diversas
culturas em diversos fusos horários de
diversas formas
isso quer dizer o quê que conectados à
internet
a gente vai para um lugar de integração
que independente da nossa localização
geográfica
nós estamos num lugar nesse ambiente
virtual
diante dessas duas observações por um
tempo eu fiquei me questionando e afinal
o lugar importa ou não importa
e essa inquietação me levou pra viver
algumas experiências ea partir delas eu
pude me dá conta que sim
o lugar importa eu escolhi três
experiências para compartilhar com vocês
que me levaram a essa constatação
então lá em junho de 2013 não sei se
vocês se lembram dessa época que
diversas manifestações aconteceram no
brasil
a inicial aqui me chamou a minha atenção
foi aquela primeira em são paulo
e as pessoas foram às ruas para se
manifestar contra o aumento do
transporte coletivo e dias depois é e no
facebook haviam diversos eventos
chamando para uma manifestação aqui eu
fui é muito curiosa pra entender como
que isso se organizava como que as
pessoas estavam reivindicando isso
e à medida que o tempo foi passando eo
facebook foi bombando neste chamado e as
pessoas começaram a irrealmente a as
ruas as faltas começaram a se
diversificar então do transporte
coletivo começaram a surgir questões de
educação de saúde
nós estávamos na véspera da copa do
mundo e então as denúncias sobre os
investimentos públicos na infraestrutura
das cidades
e aí a minha curiosidade continuava
aumentando ao mesmo tempo que eu ficava
me perguntando nossa como é que eu posso
contribuir para de alguma forma resolver
esses problemas que estamos nos
manifestando e aí naquela época eu
estava estudando democracia
participativa então me imbuído dessa
persona pesquisadora
fiz um questionário peguei uma prancheta
e fui para a manifestação daquela noite
porque eu queria entender quem são essas
pessoas o que fazem com que elas estejam
aqui e por meu azar
naquela noite choveu torrencialmente
então imaginem eu lá com o meu
guarda-chuva com uma prancheta chegava
nas pessoas e elas me olhavam quem quer
ct cantando tabular dados nessa sobre
mim e foi uma experiência muito
desafiador e voltei pra casa totalmente
frustrada eu acho que eu devo ter feito
umas dez entrevistas que eu nunca tabu
ley e e dentro dessa frustração a
curiosidade continuava e nesse período é
eu recebi pelo facebook um convite pra
curtir uma página chamada salvemos o
bosque da casa go e esse convite
é q apareceu pra esse coletivo era
dessas pessoas é denunciando que o
último remanescente verde da área
central de curitiba esse bosque estava
ameaçado de virar uma rua para acesso ao
shopping center que está ali atrás e
como ele ali pertinho da minha casa e
diante desse absurdo urbanístico fui eu
lá ver quem são essas pessoas como é que
eu posso contribuir então sair de trás
da tela do meu computador e fui é atrás
dessa realidade que se manifestava pra
mim e no início como vocês podem ver por
essa foto
os portões estavam fechados então era
uma área pública nós não tínhamos acesso
e posteriormente esses portões foram
abertos então nós poder podíamos usar o
espaço onde fizemos diversas atividades
e eu escolhi três experiências para
compartilhar com vocês
a primeira experiência ela foi o número
que era mutirão de mosaico mosaico é uma
atividade tão singelo é tão simples mas
nós religiosamente todo sábado tínhamos
um convite no facebook para qualquer
pessoa que quisesse aparecer
nós recebemos doações ou levávamos os
mosaicos que nós tínhamos nas pastilhas
posteriormente a gente começou a
utilizar tampinhas de garrafas de
plástico e ao longo dessas duas horas
mais ou menos que nós ficávamos ali além
de fazermos um mosaico a gente começou a
compartilhar as nossas histórias das
nossas vidas então para além do mosaico
a gente começou a ter 60 as relações e
esse foi o primeiro banco que nós
fizemos
então deixamos de presente para o parque
e esse banco foi palco de diversos
atividades foi um lugar onde a gente
sentava para contemplar as pessoas que
chegavam muitas crianças que chegaram na
barriga depois foram crescendo algumas
que chegaram pequenas e também viraram
crianças maiores
outras que chega
eram adolescentes e viraram adultos
então esse esse banco é muito simbólico
que é indica toda essa história que nós
fomos vivendo juntos o que eu aprendi
com um com a experiência do mundo é que
uma atividade tão singelas ela é simples
ela pode ser tão grandiosa porque a
gente está disponibilizando nosso tempo
para construir algo que talvez sozinho a
gente até poderia fazer mas vou
compartilhar nosso tempo nosso espaço
a gente vai trocando e construindo algo
coletivamente a segunda experiência
foram das feiras de troca
não fizemos só uma fizemos várias ao
longo desses quatro anos que o coletivo
ficou imobilizado e as feiras de troca
elas são muito simples também porque é
um convite das crianças levarem seus
brinquedos aqueles que elas não querem
mais utilizar para trocar com outras
crianças
essa primeira foto que eu escolhi foi da
1ª feira que nós fizemos foi na época
onde o parque ainda estava fechado então
nós precisamos na rua do lado de fora e
saindo da de trás do meu computador para
estar ali eu pude vivenciar então não só
observar mais sentindo meu corpo esse
momento que foi muito sublime onde esses
meninos que vieram de áreas diferentes
da cidade diferentes regiões que não se
conheciam de repente por um interesse
cada um no brinquedo do outro trocaram
brincaram correram fizeram essa amizade
e depois cada um com suas famílias se
separaram e voltaram para suas casas
e por que isso me tocou tanto eu até
fico emocionada de falar sobre isso
porque as crianças elas têm uma
sabedoria muito genuína que é através
desse desinteresse pelo pela questão
material mas pelo seu interesse em fazer
aquele tipo de brincadeira elas viveram
uma amizade efêmera viver
o presente sem pensar no futuro sem
pensar enquanto que o brinquedo vale o
estado de conservação e estavam ali
presentes ea cidade fez o convite para
que elas estivessem ali e viver sem esse
momento
então a cidade chamando ea gente se
disponibilizando a sair de onde estamos
pra encontrar uma pessoa ou a
diversidade a gente pode descobrir
coisas que sozinhos a gente não viveria
aqui só mostrando pra vocês uma foto de
uma das últimas coisas que nós fizemos
para vocês verem a dimensão que começa
pequeno e depois esta essa ideia vai se
espalhando e trazendo muito mais pessoas
para o espaço ea terceira experiência
foi com a horta labirinto então a nossa
horta foi plantada dentro dos princípios
agro florestais onde a natureza ela se
auto regula esse equilíbrio na produção
dos alimentos e sem utilizar nem
químicos e nem fertilizantes
e foi com essa experiência que eu
descobrir porque eu gosto tanto de pizza
marguerita numa horta agroflorestal o
manjericão ele cuida do tomate porque
uma jericã ele tem propriedades que
espantam os insetos que impedem o
crescimento do tomate
então é uma sabedoria tão pequena o tão
grandiosa da natureza mas que talvez se
eu não tivesse vivido essa experiência
jamais saberia é de por que isso
acontece ea horta labirinto ela foi a
gente começou ela é pequenininha depois
ela foi crescendo na produção das
hortaliças das ervas flores comestíveis
a gente começou a praticar a compostagem
que a transformação dos resíduos
orgânicos em adubo então o nosso resíduo
orgânico era compostado ali que ia para
a horta a horta dava mais alimentos que
viravam o nosso composto que virava
dunga então a gente fechou nesse ciclo e
essa experiência
foi crescendo junto com as árvores com o
que estava plantado ali e nós podemos
apoiar outras iniciativas para além do
parque go
moradora do golã e foi notificado pela
prefeitura porque ele tinha bananeiras
na sua calçada e bananeiras não são
espécies de arborização então a
prefeitura notificou para que ele
cortasse e uma horta que tinha é de
calçado no bairro cristo rei também foi
notificada dizendo que importa não é
grama então que ele deveria desfazer
essa essa ordem então nós fomos é apoiar
essas iniciativas e lá todo final de
semana cultivando e chamando a atenção
da imprensa das pessoas usando muito
facebook é ajudou com que eles fossem
recebidos pelo prefeito então essas
notificações caíram eles não foram
multados e acabou ajudando na aprovação
da lei de agricultura urbana
então a força desse coletivo que começou
pequenininha como vocês puderam ver na
na primeira foto usando as redes sociais
para chamar mais pessoas pra falar de
todos os temas que envolviam ali naquele
espaço a gente rompeu as fronteiras do
próprio espaço do parque e pudemos é
apoiar outras iniciativas então isso
mostra a força do coletivo essa é
através de pequenas atividades mesmo
singelas ou muito simples revelam uma
grandiosidade e diante dessas
experiências desses quatro anos que nós
ficamos mobilizados em 2016 o parque foi
a partir de um decreto do prefeito
ele foi criado então essa ameaça a all
boys que ser destruído foi minimizada e
eu pude perceber que ao longo desse
tempo eu tinha uma motivação muito forte
né que diante dessa ameaça então no
início me fiz a minha motivação de estar
ali era sobre a ameaça e observa
as pessoas eu fui vendo que a maior
parte não estava ali por causa disso que
essa convivência e se fazer coletivo
tudo que nós vivenciamos nesse espaço é
talvez tenha superado o real motivador
desse coletivo ter se juntado e aí eu
percebi também diante da diversidade
dessas pessoas que vinham de diversos
lugares da cidade e diversas orientações
políticas por exemplo
mais do que tentar convencer o outro ou
de haver um consenso mas que a gente
conseguia conviver e para além das
nossas dever das nossas divergências e
preferências ou diferenças quando a
gente compartilha o tempo e troca essas
histórias e isso foi um grande exercício
de cidadania que foi muito importante
pra mim e essa minha história e eu e
qual é a história de vocês que revela a
potência das cidades que vem a partir do
encontro
então eu convido vocês pra olhar em
quais são os convites digitais que esse
mundo virtual
aparece aí nossa sua na sua tela que
convida você a viver a potência da sua
cidade
obrigado
[Aplausos]